this is Howard he's four months old he
lives in California with his family to
kid his mom Domino is his dad and Boo is
his sister
they are pileated Gibbons this species
is found in Thailand Cambodia and Laos
in the wild they are threatened by
habitat destruction and the wild animal
trade they live mostly in trees and all
Gibbons have strong arms and legs the
long muscular arms help them move
through the branches with impressive
speed romantic by Nature pileated Gibbon
couples are usually monogamous often
staying with their partners for life
given couples form strong bonds grooming
each other and hanging out in trees both
males and females are similar in size
and have a cooperative family dynamic
families do everything together and when
the children are grown they lead to
create their own families BB Gibbons
learn how to grasp their mothers hair
from early on and will nurse for the
first two years of their life
Howard hasn't started swinging on his
own yet but he'll be ready to start
learning soon this is the pileated
Gibbon
[Music]